[Music]
[Applause]
what up everyone hello we're back again
we brought a good friend of ours Evan
the dream master thanks for having me
all right can I call you the dream
master I guess uh
evan is our our dream maestro even yeah
and we're your acquaintance dreams cuz
it came out today finally uh we're gonna
try to play some of you guys's levels or
just we're gonna cruise around and find
things you might hear metal your music
in the background that's because I found
a metal gear dream Joe Lucas here too
and he's brought all of you with him
what's up on a chat pad so he explained
what the stream is what we're doing yeah
we're playing dreams we're playing ones
that you guys want to recommend to us
once you guys have made but in the
meantime I'm just so good yeah so we're
gonna play some dreams is out today if
you have a dreams level that you've made
it or a dreams level that you've seen
that you want us to play please send it
our way I'll be monitoring chat oh I'm
having a very good time I hope both of
your dreams will come true today I hope
your dream comes true I hope everyone's
dreams come true come comes true your
dreams
so I guess while we wait for people to
bring levels in we'll just play some mom
yeah you can one here all your dream
maestro you've gotta take a so this is
the your dream surfing right now it's
the it's the dream surf well you can you
can see all of these levels people have
made arts dream is the kind of
single-player both at Media Molecule
has made to go along with final race of
the game which is cool uh let's see what
here's the most thumbed up dreams I'm
just saying that made one makes a lot of
sense where's the beyblade well over the
Left battle tops alright let's do it
player okay let's tops let's just try it
yeah alright okay alright oh you gotta
like oh so thank you you price oh god
there's another there's a big one on the
oh boy
I did I let her it's just a multiplayer
like
like beyblade yeah I guess so yeah I
think you can have four people come in
yeah so Dreamz does support that you can
do multiplayer games they're gonna add
VR in a later update I believe mm-hmm
also I don't know if multiplayer already
lost I have to watch this I don't know
if multi players available right now
actually really even I launched yeah
they're uh they're adding more things
post launcher might have been online
multiplayer that's not available yet I'm
uh this reminds me I don't I want to
give me a giveaway of a million dollar
idea of I mean ten we're talking about
like a battle royale but with beyblades
[Music]
almost kind of almost there so some
people when they release levels as well
they can make it so that people can
remix those levels and like see how they
were made so you can also like kind of
take some of their parts they'll get a
credit automatically in your level if
you do that yeah but that is an option I
think I think you picked up where I left
off cuz I played this a little bit when
we're sending off VR machines it's real
important though
okay let's no not wait now does that
mean it's actually in VR or is it like
it's just about to get referenced I
think it might be a Metal Gear reference
but I think it's also where is where is
like the levels available right now oh
it is okay sweet heck yeah
where was Hatsune Miku's at it again
there's Minecraft right there mine is a
prototype but we could check it out yeah
let's play a little minecraft worlds
policy you have like developer patch
notes I like it well I'll admit that
looks really good it doesn't yet
texture-wise wow that's gonna be nailed
it 360 noscopes the music's all there
too yeah I didn't realize until I
actually like looked at it but dreams
like let's you make everything yeah I
didn't realize you could make music on
top of the levels until it's literally
everything mm-hmm yeah so like people
can also upload just like creation it's
not like a full level so it's like you
want to make like a fully scaled up
character or yeah you want to just like
upload
music just like even an asset for
somebody to use you can do that this is
very good someone made a hamburger and I
was staring at it this is a top tier
concept yeah you're saying so I made
just like a bunch of food yeah just just
do a quick search for food okay like
just see what there is look it's the
silent hill's I played halfway through
that it's like a full game I don't know
what they've done okay we have to check
that out there I was looking at my food
for a date for a date all right just
drop on in and it it lets you kind of
like look at all the things on the table
that's good and then you go to that
hamburger though just press press right
the hamburgers
the seeds on that bun do that's good the
melty cheese those fries are like super
symmetrical yeah they're they're stacked
to well that that beef looks juicy as
heck right impressive yeah this is in
that weird like also a weird fuzzy dream
texture nonsense but they made it look
like this yeah yeah you can also make
like movies and dreams if you want like
you could play around with the
cinematics and the camera like this
person did very well yeah you can also
free look if you want to okay you get
inside of that hamburger really fast and
soils what it's made out of it's you oh
wait so you can see the yeah when you
get real deep in there you can see the
textures of the me the dream textures
their dream meat jell-o jell-o is really
good you got some noodles over here Oh
keychain I don't even see the knot
Luden's keychain I was gonna say is that
Luton sort of Wow
I'm soda some soda pop I wonder how long
this took that I wish that there was a
way to kind of tell like maybe before
you pick it kind of like I think you can
five hours no wait a burger coffee
colorful nothing to report it this is
too good some of it of course I think I
was oh here details Oh
please like a hole used intently like
used in ten other creations versions and
release let's see let's go let's go all
the way back yes yes well I didn't
realize you could track all this yeah
this is all available I mean I mean you
can choose not to have it on there but I
think by default as I was saying earlier
you can make it so that like when a
label goes out someone can remix it and
like use it in their level and like try
different things with it or you can just
release it as as is oh yeah you can see
like they saved it online like at all
these different dates hmm and I think
you can click like old versions well
yeah so like this you can add version
notes so it's like this one says no
version notes but maybe yeah no that's
there's nothing on there but I think can
you play the I think you play the older
version we do yeah oh wow oh wow the
beta tested versions you can always go
back and get the beta hamburger so I
think these are all the versions that
were just uploaded so this person
could've been working on it like locally
before they arrived and they just made
new versions that they uploaded so
fascinating yeah okay I need it I need
to know what that silent hill's one
looks like it's a lot they've they wrote
their own fanfiction like they made an
entire store I never got to the PT like
any of that stuff edge right yeah oh
yeah please
it's actually really impressive there's
some dialogue options and characters
that are voiced dad was dead yeah they
basically made Silent Hill is impressive
I will be coming back that doesn't play
until the end though so this isn't PT oh
they made like a main team maybe in a
silent hill's game oh
stuff from PT oh wow
with like characters and voice acting
they brought the they brought it to life
yeah they made their dreams come true
they made their dreams come true yes
move Renan no this is so silly intro
okay like cutscene there's areas my
favorite dreams it's Norman Reedus
oh yeah dude a lot of really good like
scenes they use a lot of the stuff like
audio wise and yeah yeah really good
lighting too
[Music]
just like the demo no can you control it
out no no so this is like the end of the
demo when it shows right goes out and
then the title screens gonna come up
it's gonna be really bright because
that's how I got to do it okay okay so
this is like a - yeah yeah they're like
recreating the ending mmm
to carry you over into their full game
that they've made wow that is amazing
dude
bread 5 since I just got here what'd I
miss we're playing silent white silent
hill's my dude
yeah Kojima sent us a copy he was like
here you go just kidding no so many
dreams made this and they're very
impressive
I like watermark yeah that's just the
whole game every menu every place yep
been they've got their own voice acting
subtitled in everything Jeffrey Jeffrey
Allen Hill Police Department
This Is It this is amazing I love this
yeah it's so good there's so much that
went into this and it's apparent
throughout the whole thing
I actually had to stop because it
wouldn't it just was more Oh Norman
Reedus
not making too many deliveries nowadays
I guess I see they made the bold choice
to switch you back to third person the
first person compared our volumes
because it's hard to keep track of the
dreams yeah the sound mixing changes
depending on the game you push these
copies means excuse me sir I'm a
detective
I'm a detective hey excuse me say put
down on the table let me tell you
something yes this is really important
stuff yep thanks for coming in my TED
talk okay bye oh man
excuse me yeah I have I need to see I
need I need this whole counter yeah I
mean though for me please
maybe the whole counter please thank you
yep really interesting okay bye guys oh
whoa like a TV show oh wow yeah they've
got like you know the sounds the
backgrounds there's people like talking
and you hear scribbles like people
taking notes okay chief of police we're
already short on people
I didn't ask and it's a good morning so
just getting harder and harder every day
Jeffrey
also what is dreams rated is it is a
teen or is it that's a good point
cuz this guy's like eyes his wife got
shot by her husband in the stomach you
could definitely make it not team yeah I
think I'm sure they have like some sort
of concert is a censorship type of tools
yeah I think it's along lines of like
their content is rated a certain way but
then it's like one of those like yeah
yeah yeah I think there's like a thing
it's like on yeah online interactions
are considered unrated because yeah
something like that and it's like I
wonder like if you have like a parental
control to count or something like that
if it would limit something I don't I
don't have that kind stuff works
actually the tools are so complex I
don't know how you would be able to
properly like censor things yeah
dialogue choices oh wow I wasn't paying
attention any possible I can't think of
any
just ask him how how will he know
totally out of the out of the blue this
is crazy
yeah I love the dialogue options yeah a
little bit of a le noir in there yeah
yeah less police sketching though which
is kind of sad Cole Phelps is always
great at sketching we know how long this
is no I waited for like 15 minutes and
it didn't stop wow I can I guess not
been any point move on to something else
yeah I want to move on yeah volume is
too quiet people are saying like a boost
it a little bit let's see is there
something yes would potentially want to
see yes is there anything
you guys know about or you wanna see
yeah
these are Media Molecule what happened
to the top rated that we were looking at
new trending dreams maybe
let's see Star Wars Star Wars we lose
digimon armor oh Expo so we can check
out some dishes check out some sweet
model Digimon really quick gold armor
energized life I wasn't ready oh what's
this
oh my doing oh you actually get to run
around as them whoa dang I felt like it
was coming right at me
Rudo run did you wanna run like that I
think I think some of them do I can I
try - oh no I guess you got involved we
should go back and you're going to
evolve again oh here's a different
solution yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
boy okay whoa oh sweet lightning strike
do it do it
Oh dad - hold it I think you have to
hold it yeah I'm holding it oh all right
I think touchpad oh yeah I can see that
that golden armor did you fall oh my
goodness this is a cool piece of proof
the concept it's just like the anime
yeah
I don't know okay a couple people are
said some things that I assume our
dreams recommendations
Babbitt ood is that should I spell that
cement habit une do I spell ba ba ba
father has returned yes o most I can do
with the limited gameplay thermo
character too complex for regional
adventure game plans alright let's check
it out see what's going on all right all
right
whoa that running animation looks legit
yeah it is kind of endearing how some of
the the running works and dreams but
it's really good when you get animation
oh this looks legit oh my goodness oh oh
flashes yeah yeah beat them up
oh oh I get it babbit ood is like your
meter charging it oh can I like learn
him into the fire
whoa well am i my helpers on the bottom
oh boy I think yours is the top one over
the special meter oh you've got my
controls lay out if you need to see it
with us sick
Oh double gel okay oh I can kick okay
Pullman kick we can lock on ya block in
the air jump punch Oh ground slam there
we go there we are
and you got your specials back weird uh
oh wait lock on okay
I hope so it makes like a fighting game
like a cheetah fighting game in this
yeah really good so can I like jump in
the air and be like BAM no no the effort
was there this is a very good
recommendation
yeah it is very good okay super stick
media for a recommendation is super sick
media you are super sick heck yeah
also it's pronounced Babatunde Oh
apparently how you pronounce it cool
Am I am I gonna hit too yeah you know
that you're help artisans at the top but
I feel like every time I'm hitting him
Maya also goes down nice can you get rid
of the of yeah good Y all around the
mint I really like it whenever there's
like a good kind of 3d I want someone to
make us secretly got hands country wow
you said it it's gonna happen mm-hmm
I think what's great with dreams too is
like you know the early access creations
and maybe the beta creations I don't
know have carried over but like now like
the game is out people can continue
creating things for years ahead and
really like what the silent hill's game
is really impressive for what was made
at the time so in time I mean like I
think that really actually came out back
in April so if they started all the way
back then it hasn't been a year and they
did all that which is super cool
it can only give manner can only get
better and you can like collaborate on
dreams with people so like multiple
people can work on a single dream so
like one person could do music I
personally do characters so there's the
things I've been crediting people for
yeah different parts yeah let me hit up
fiver yeah you like I need someone to
make me yeah boy second my dreams game
yeah so yeah I think if media molecules
art dreams creation is supposed to I
mean it's great but it's also like an
inspiration people like you know be
better than this wow that's cool one of
us
oh okay I think I almost got that guy
but he's almost also gone yeah the
double jump animation takes me places
I'm just punching I guess yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh he was the bottom yeah
yeah yeah oh I had those mix up the
whole time that's great
thumbs up yeah huge thumbs up ten do you
have any other recommend you have a ton
okay great uh let's see we have
detective Pig all right which I'm into
that
detective Pig uh detective Pig there's
detective Pig advent calendar there's
take detective Halloween special Pig
detective to adventures in cowboy -
which one do we hit detective three we
gotta start with one my feeling guys
start with one yeah let's let's do this
one Pig detective one a little trouble
in a little clone new remastered edition
with voice acts all thank goodness view
okay so this is other thing to some
levels you can like view it like you can
just straight up go into it and like go
and be like see how they made it oh
that's neat
but let's play it I don't spoil anything
ooh do you want to play the remaster
yeah we got all right
just the brightness changing anything
here that music
I'll go with that I guess Sheriff oh man
the cheese desk hello Steve
I'm here for cheese yes I guess now
let's ask about Gloria we're getting a
lot of recommendations now this is
excellent this is perfect
though I kind of almost default dreams
walk is maybe one of my favorite thing
where you're in the bathroom hey what's
up its me Pig this acting yo sup guys me
nearly as well as I hope where's Gloria
oh yeah glory wait wait wait chillin Oh
should go turn off that water in the
bathtub that was it oh here we get the
brightness go okay okay here we go yes
oh I have to click it got it that it was
Wednesday
it is Wednesday my Pig dudes a day like
any other she strolled into my office
no no you
my bouncer butch he got arrested but
he's innocent and the best bouncer in
town case accepted just like that huh
big detective you're picked it was the
best detective in town jeez
he's at the police station remember did
Pig detective just forget I think maybe
ah
so she wanted the cheese anyway uh can I
do it click can I do that I don't wanna
forget yeah well you seem over you know
hello so really like how water looks and
dreams a lot noticed oh yeah it's on the
table don't can't take a bath alright
let's do one more scene okay the only
article of clothing that effective is
wearing as I had oh there you go
okay yep cool I like how that opened the
elevator yeah
this is fantastic
well why why okay I'll exit then do like
a point click adventure game like that's
kind of what there's gonna say this is
remind me like a girlfriend dango yeah
yeah India they're like 1920s yeah thing
is very little rats wait there's like
the mouse woman lady but also normal
rats don't think about okay yeah it was
a donut shop down there Richard hives do
scum and villainy that's a good
referential save the time for a drink
hey this isn't a flashback yeah tell her
dude yeah okay let's go good don't it
there's a police station over there
that's where she told us to go yeah this
is the time for don't have time for
don't see they're trying to hold me back
to what I'm just gonna making my way
downtown walk in slowly to the police
station this is pig Detective physics
Pig detective 1 remaster yeah remaster
version of one there's like five Pig
detective yeah
[Music]
The Voice I think is pretty good yeah
she's not in a good mood screw up and
talk to Lane
yeah but he's he's out of doughnuts what
if we get him yeah oh we don't know
that's that's what happens though what
happens what you're gonna do yeah what
do you do arrest me I'm a detective
okay all right
taxi all right now is this we'll get the
doughnuts and then we'll open and then
we'll do it Jake wants to know where's
Callie playing Pokemon Callie back yeah
another Pokemon there's dreams came out
today and we thought it'd be a cool
thing to kind of show often a different
way of doing community Friday instead of
like playing with people more like show
us what you've done in dreams if you
have things or things that you think are
good all right all right let's talk to
the guy
let's give him his name well we'll move
on we have a ton of recommendations I'm
going to probably play a lot of these
games yeah later yeah this week like
whenever you find like a really good one
like this there I've already had the
moment where I forgot that I'm playing
dreams and I'm I'm I think I'm playing
like a regular game if though she's
really good Katzie can cats eat donuts
can't have a little donut okay like a
dozen
there we go I hope you enjoy your Donuts
smack oh gotta get to Tahiti I have a
plan to get out of here work like this
close up yeah this I think is fantastic
very good we should do a let's play
series we just play all of the big
detective games yes my favorite crime
series whoa is that a fourth wall break
oh that's cool looking so that's
fantastic make sure don't like that once
yeah absolutely
okay what's next we have
the ancient temple game uh okay
I don't know this is real someone said
coach her for kotor for Hamtaro returns
you know it was there's only one way to
find out was the wrath of revin yep
like coat like that code yeah that might
be just I don't know if that was someone
just making a joke game taro just humor
me really quick how do I spell H AMT aro
somebody being a Batman Arkham game
there's Rogers Hamtaro take me in
okay let's play chicken let's take a
quick sigh he's got that it's probably
not much to it yeah might just be the
oh they have their own logo love it Wow
yeah that's cool
uh okay oh that's Hamtaro maybe aunt
Ayano skits a hangout is sort of a proof
of concept
yeah like aunt ro exists and dreams
Jilla
that's a good-looking avatar oh yeah
right yeah yeah you can admire it
alright okay next up let's try sacred
serenity sacred serenity epic saber duel
cool or a little big planet okay there
you go sweet whoa I'm already digging
this
had 1k likes uh so you want to know some
really good as this first person like
atmosphere stuff that I've found already
someone made the area from the end of
Metal Gear Solid 3 and whenever you hold
down the square button it changes all
the plants to red and I almost cried at
my desk Metal Gear this is really good
look this is impressive
Wow music this is like something I would
legit put in my um my portfolio yeah
it's just like an art as an artist no I
think this is this is a hard this is all
legitimate this is yeah like look at
like this is an example of some like
environmental design work I did and
dreams like yeah babies like it is it's
a hundred percent of creation tool you
could get that fountains come true I
know I keep saying that but I we will
definitely at some point hear a story
about like somebody who got hired based
on like I think they made a dream yeah
actually I think someone was hired at
Media Molecule because there's some
creations and dreams I want to see like
I don't know like somebody made like
such a good like I got hired like on
Halo infinite because of my weapon
concepts from dreams yeah exactly
or like something like that I now do
environmental design for Dark Souls yeah
yeah this is very impressive
oh is it like nighttime
uh yeah whatever let's go for it hell
yeah do it
no won't let me man makin barriers I get
backed up now nope maybe not the walls
kind of fuzzy yeah well I think we got
to show it off a little bit yeah okay
that's really nice that's cool I'm too
impressed with that I give that alike Oh
yep definitely I need anything we play
it's good you should give it a like okay
let's see
our PD which I assume is racoon Police
Department I hope so are you if somebody
just recreated oh I'll try all caps I
don't know if that you probably just
search probably not try a wingsuit world
is that one the word wingsuit yes whoo
so me the Black Lodge between people do
you see that I didn't see that wingsuit
world
yup yeah oh you've already played it Oh
have I yeah I check this out
I have played this it's good no I
honestly don't remember I think I played
it a while ago
whoa we got the Chams oh boy oh yeah you
gotta hit the balloons right
oh no the flyby camera oh wait how do I
go up no no oh my god I died okay okay
oh I'm sorry two to go fast gotta go
fast it is sonic day after all am i what
steering what am I doing wrong
or is it like perpetually going down
shoot your glove oh okay okay you can
only okay okay so you have to go fast
enough to not hit that every guard is
you got that pop bonus okay let's go
everywhere you go out cuz how would you
hit those yeah I think you'd like be
very precise hit the balloons
this is cool oh we got a couple
somebody's recommending their game oh
this is pretty cool though this is cool
this is tough actually cuz you like
can't hit the environment but you can
move up and down oh the car yeah Oh
nailed it
okay gotta go fast to do do this this
one last run in the middle jump into
that other one yeah if I can get those
balloons okay the fact that ever the
screen gets really red whenever you get
close to something is a lot good oh oh
geez you have to go fast okay this hall
this is all making sense to me let's go
let's try it's called a Connie's mansion
ooh like Co Anna and ie
yeah danger cone like is there an
apostrophe it doesn't say there's an
apostrophe just but Ness Castle mansion
mansion no I just saw it I see yeah
there you go there there it is I'm
hoping this is yours is this is the same
username yep that is heck yeah let's
play it Hani's mansion
[Music]
I love that you can have your own like
well the whole presentation credits
you've been invited
subscribe you and other mansions you've
been to Luigi's Mansion
Connie's mansion
yeah there's those ghosts say that is oh
yes you're Connie with this is perfect
for you oh my goodness oh my goodness
you're right for context my favorite
game of 2019 was Luigi's Mansion three I
also did else locked I also did a lot of
the Attic up those stairs right I also
did a lot of the video coverage of
Luigi's Mansion three at the time that
ended up in my top ten as well it was uh
it's just perfectly like a game for me
yeah because I just love those like it's
like single-player it's ten hours like
every level is super uniquely designed
yeah I love slamming ghosts I felt that
was such a great mechanic co-op
surprisingly good these doors so many
doors to choose that one let's seems
like the most suspicious Oh No darn it
unusable is everybody zoom in okay all
right okay
I like oh here we go here we go okay
bedroom I see a key are you thinking
around that right yeah unlock living
room in the foyer kind of a flashlight
some good and ominous music happening
this is great and there's a really good
um okay check the other universe no
unusable well that one was locked so
maybe that's what the key I wonder if
all the other ones are unusable yeah so
if you try that middle one yeah it's not
that one it's probably the one that's
out in the main area this one the door
for the key
she's one down on the look I see yeah is
that the way is that what a four year is
oh yes thank you
I obviously don't know what if we're
here
not many people say it nowadays oh yeah
I've got the I've got the vacuum oh boy
oh my gosh yes yes Morgause get him oh
and now it's like it lights up like in
the game like the room lights up and you
catch off it goes love it okay turn on
the TV
no all right all right place let's try
one more room okay let's go oh my
goodness
a whole group of them take two for one
they dude I'm the Luigi's Mansion master
I mean the connie's mansion they
interact in the fridge yeah well I know
on the the table oh good i okay we got
the game room looks like okay is that is
that why is this is that back in the
other place we've been the one that was
locked there okay oh it's tears on this
side too yeah that's what that little
camera turn is
cool mansion okay uh I think it's up
there yeah probably the store now let's
see let's find out
yeah nice all right there we go
oh I got him they seem to very much be
enjoying this the the ghost sounds are
maybe my favorite I think it's time to
do something else
that is excellent thank you for the
letting us play your level that was
really good
that was very great all right what a fan
do you like it that was that was amazing
okay let's see so I didn't expect to see
Luigi's Mansion game I didn't either
let's see what we've got here we I'm
going back
[Music]
you
super jump is that one word keywords
sonic breeze super Joe uh might not have
that anymore
let me see somebody mentioned to wipeout
clone but they didn't say what I love
wipeout what it is wipeout oh god that
was a Petey face I saw that
sideout liquid side out is this ooh yeah
that's it do that is someone made some
drum and bass music oh they got like a
menu screen oh I guess time attack yeah
what is dreams even oh cool red one mad
water city here I go horse crap oh my
dude like this is one of ones I hope is
really loud because I feel like it has
to be oh and they give you like this
little like just like cinematic of the
level alright let's go over all right
what if I look yeah how do I play oh boy
I'm hoping it's our - nope not our two
attacks
Petrus don't use the the triggers for it
I've got it
do this legit
oh what a turn oh my goodness so clean I
imagine people will make f-zero games in
here too
Oh yours hope oh you have bounce bring
out I wiped out
hey you slid out I guess nope no all
right
furfrou third time's the charm yeah here
we go
there we go nice alright okay third
time's the charm you got it we can do
this yeah there you go we go forth
Dempster no oh but oh you're going the
wrong way now okay I got don't worry
guys it's under control
everything's being handled yeah
technical difficulties please stand just
exploring the extents of the map you
know I've been hiring
I'm very much admiring this oh oh I win
I think your your health ran out oh well
checkpointing is pretty good though yeah
I know I think it turned around again
you you are you are correct
oh we're about to do the the big like
loop-de-loop thing the UI looks really
clean
yeah all right let's do this
do I have to say stick okay all right
all right I got this
so when you guys first had wipeout I
thought of the TV show wipeout like that
games I know yeah you like they try to
knock you off and but this this is also
excellent TT airplay wipeout in first
person I'd like TR yeah pretty legit I
played in VR and then the speed someone
here I imagine that the sense of speed
is very high it is anytime you go into
first person everything just seems like
it's faster I enjoy it
boom there you go lap done sweet damn oh
yeah please do
yes that is okay let's see um 30 19
somebody said there is a monster sim /
Godzilla sim I'm into that let me look
up Godzilla yeah I'm sure there's a ton
of Godzilla content is he and Joey go to
a movie oh king in Queen battle the
tyrant uh hold on so this is a thing you
look at what's is still art okay that's
pretty impressive that Wow cool thumb up
it I like it if you like this is this is
the next strand game by the way give it
a like let's say there you go the god
maybe it's the monster raids again yeah
that's another one shoot Godzilla shoot
that that could be it okay there's a
couple we got here how do you only go to
those I'm good you do this flight
schedule yeah okay doo doo doo doo look
at me oh I'm surprised at the lack of
Jojo content on here are the controls
oh wait okay that's a very good-looking
guy yeah that's my liking oh there we go
I like this a lot a van we need for
Godzilla video games oh my god there we
go
this is cute
okay never last for only let me let me
try to plasma breath this building I
love the segmented tails so much that is
a legit looking Godzilla it's yeah yeah
it's really good what do you pick up the
whole thing
Oh grab it just crush it alright hey
it's me you boy Godzilla pack yah to the
end don't forget to Like and subscribe
for more building destruction oh you
can't kill things in detail perfect he's
gonna kind of walk you know it like fire
breath this thing they got the music in
every yeah this is so much it's real
good alright you just toss that wheel I
don't think so okay somebody ok the
off-road lands off-road liam's off-road
lands I don't know yes the off-road land
hey
Drive Thru it's a driving game oh yeah
so you gotta hit that horn right away oh
when it comes out the controller oh okay
cedrus okay arcade handling deactivated
oh you can like switch the the control
scheme appreciate the drifting going
offroad voice says let's play another
driving one I'm surprised how how well
people can make cars controlling us - OH
snowing now do I have the right tires oh
you betcha
babe get the Fountain of Youth right
here oh man gone forever
is it more slippery yeah it is so cool
that is a nice touch okay the lodge will
creep you lies and you'll know where
you'll come running that's no man oh you
gotta look at the snow being displaced
by the tires - it's just a small thing
but you know yeah we're gonna get out of
the car or should I just ran to the
house there you go I think you go with a
garage sweet oh my got the snowman thing
in my car upgrades man nice
sweet little twist turn Vin Diesel over
here it started a little avalanche I
guess with a bunch of SS X this is X so
much I'm sure there's a snowboarding you
oh here we go
oh my god another worldly adventure ok
but now he found break him I Drive on
him here's a puzzle oh all those logs
open his mouth where am I going onward
to adventure wonder if that was scary
whew sorry it's I didn't expect there to
be school this is really cruel this is a
great
well no like this price go right through
yeah China swords am I the chosen one
only one way to find out the Jeep
Wrangler Yanni is so weird you got your
mark yeah
he just brought a sword to a car fight
you know they're always beautiful plan
I've been hearing Final Fantasy 14 seen
all this
what if someone recreated Final Fantasy
14 in dreams I just jump over here
what's mentioning like a Final Fantasy 7
mmm like just get the HD remake out
before they do let's go do you guys like
my longest you have whatever oh this is
a journey yo it's beautiful
also maybe the best advertisement I've
seen for a Jeep in a long time you want
to go visit ancient temples and see some
skulls oh it's the end so visit your
grave oh my goodness rip have I taken
time it's just journey but for cars
whoa life is a highway you know what I'm
saying I'm gonna ride it all night no
you're not gonna ride it all night long
there's gonna be a what a plot twist day
that was beautiful oh my god oh poor one
oh yes thumbs up absolutely holy crap
that was amazing
try um it's aka and oh I oka ah maybe
that's like the person who made it like
is there a level no unfortunately
because this first was saying it was a
really good a sectoral like game Oh
mm-hmm I'm Sakura it still a cup sec I
don't see what happens
Thank You Doris oh it was just spelled
differently yeah I think this search and
this is like super specific on a lot of
minds all right let's go
yeah this yes I appreciate that will you
skip the tutorial ooh that's a really
good character design yeah okay let's
oh wow is it is there a lock on yeah
okay so take a camera lock clicking on
the r3 cool healing attack walk run got
a cool food yeah I don't to hold it can
I deflect it yeah you want dealing
actual oh whatever dude just like
Jonathan secured oh boy this is his
niece this is it's Gwendolyn Sakura
Gwendolyn the sicker kids Sakura
you know there were two at you at a time
he's probably ever like Marlins from
yeah oh I forgot the lock on this that
was exactly what we do I was just too
invested you'll have time reach your
head man here we go
oh there we go
then you're just about to get Gwendolyn
second road nailed it I don't know why
you call i think it's cuz vin diesel
called it's sakura that was good
how do you how do you properly pronounce
it sucky real Sakura Sakura Sakura
Sakura oh one sec you bruh
shadows died once maybe twice ooh
oh yeah it's like a legit lock on dude
you got those iframes with the Dodge I
just feel it actually looks pretty good
this is good this is like super
intuitive the lockdown really helps and
like it really does like respond to your
controls so it's like maybe I could just
make blood-borne 2 and dreams that's the
dream Oh wrong button can we produce
like a year-long series were two more
tries to make corn - he's like dream
blood-borne sequel in dreams and we just
like follow his development what what
skills do we all have that we can
contribute to game design here in the
office
[Music]
I could cut the trailer okay cool cool
we're already off to a good start having
a trailer means people knows it exists
so we'll publish a trailer first yes
before it'll just say blood-borne -
created by tomorrow hey people you've
done that before
yeah you just do you like the title
screen and just be like this is metroid
metroid prom force had it trailer out
and it's just the title and that's it
goodness oh man I'm losing it now you
can you're getting wombo combo oh two
two one Oh but what happens when you die
gasps death if you could resurrect girls
what do I choose I resurrect yeah do it
that's three of them oh boy you got it
you got it you got it
I think they killed the other one thanks
okay multiple enemies at once little
tough then uh just like an actual Secura
yeah
the moment when you you you finally kill
them and likely close your eyes and just
kind of like uh damn is uh a lot of
feedback we're getting out so many
recommendations oh my gosh you're beat
the skeletal whoa whoa whoa whoa you
just chillin
absolutely the name of this game means
red demon oh it's pretty good dude
that's like oh it's like one armed wolf
red demon yeah yeah okay good theming
damn this guy's got range oh boy
oh boy boy oh boy oh my god you've been
skeletons let's move on uh because this
is real good there's no way we're gonna
be able to get through all of these but
holy crap is very good all right what
else uh uh okay a game that was just
called somebody keeps recommending a
game called bloom
unless you're lost you
evening orchard is in bloom Vanguard
overdrive vibes from the 80 byte
animation this is short we can stop
there for a sec which won the fight
animation know which one the fighting
yeah thank you I'm curious sorority
here's just like some like a tech demo
kind of thing let's not see people
fighting you know I'll see some cool
animations oh wait this is blue is this
it oh is this it I have no idea it's not
what it's called
it said blue is it that might be this
might be it then dude this is some Monty
oh yes gonna save my dead fantasy type
[ __ ] shout-out to 2005 it's here oh the
new season a ruby looks nuts it's it's
so fast
I like the game but it's so fast whoever
was recommending bloom yeah I just know
if that was it yeah I assume that was it
over drag uh I can't believe I
accidentally picked the right thing
let's see people want us to search for
Naruto
oh yeah sure how they have a specific
game I think they just want us to look
for an art or the memes I'm in dude I
think that was the zombies man it was
yeah this open-world adventure demo
there's speedrun ooh there's ultimate
ninja verse play Sasuke Naruto versus
Sasuke all the time most iconic battles
remastered on Twitter yeah we can watch
envies oh god just saying production
what on earth is this gonna spoil this
fight for me
[Music]
you're my friends you might not come on
oh he did make he did it the same way um
he pronounced it the same way uh Yuri
Lowenthal true knows whoa
so if you have you seen you've seen this
scene then right yes how accurate is
this I mean it's been like 10 years
since I've watched probably more than
that honestly super this is president
this is hey now hey now this is
literally what dreams are made of
you know you're an all-star game of the
lines this is a long fight I don't know
this is this much longer or I mean I
don't know did they say it was short I
don't know I think this is enough of a
concept for me to understand that this
is possible and it's
okay oh wait at the end that might be it
nice no nope no yeah that's fine I think
said to transition that's a good part -
I all right you definitely like that one
right yeah okay there's a couple
you
somebody says a OS RS oh oh wait no oh
yes
RS no no results hmm maybe that's a
different name
the missing constellation looks as if
someone claims it's the best open worlds
who dreams missing oh wait the missing
constellations are there like a piano
yeah
[Music]
dude this is atmospheric Wow looks
really nice
x2 blow I think I will
[Music]
Oh armed only with a keyboard alone
warrior he sets out to deliver packages
to a broken world legit looking yeah
skipping my way down the forest just
like shallow classes vibes cute like use
your keyboard yeah unless it's like
walking around yeah I can jump and walk
can't you even I like a jump animation a
lot yeah I like we put the stars in the
air yeah this is this is wild all this
stuff people haven't been making things
for that long it's just been a couple of
months look how it sky looks - yeah this
is really really legit lookin ooh I like
the broken architecture just the
whiplash just hit me of going from that
Naruto Sasuke
yes Oh apparently OS RSS stands for old
school runescape oh so you just got
typing runescape
so I guess we're just looking up a
runescape next yeah I guess let's check
out what's up people have also been
recommending a tiny pier in 1904 tiny
Peter pier Oh tiny Peter we're gonna
Kampai the censorship that's true make
myself go this way
oh now darn alright uh okay this looks
like a bridge that's like broken bridge
okay there run No
mmm can I go up there that unattainable
might be yeah darn all right well here's
a path I guess oh yeah we are getting so
many recommendations that's that's what
I want that's what I want to see I want
to surf through all of your dreams I
promise
do we want to move on from this one I
guess I mean it looks cool I check out
more of it feel free to stop me at any
point you're good all right let's try
the the runescape one okay I'm with a
brooms Keith runescape the last time I
played runescape there was only the one
version of it there's M scape scape is
probably it because oh that that's what
the things are called they're called
imps yeah is this halo all right I don't
know if this is the one but let's try
it's a it's a runescape thing I'm sure
yep we're here we've made it login
remember to use logout
we are you actually playing with other
people though I doubt it stand here to
fish you need a fishing rod and here you
would chop and skill up
wait this melee oh no hmm
yo-yo
massage buddy oh hey whoa even got the
flippin contacts wait wait no no wait oh
wait oh wait mom how do I beat him up
with my beating him up you fish I got
him
okay what's this fishing off 50 to craft
a fishing rod and then you need a fish
okay
did his beat-up villagers till they give
me a fishing around give me a fishing
rod think you have to make one
give me a fishing rod oh there's a
there's just over there hope you're
right well I gotta kill this guy first
okay just
okay you buy stuff that's pretty cool
cold how do I get gold all right I think
we should move on B yeah I'm gonna like
this though no it's cool my tiny peer
let's try a tiny Peter I still need a
tiny Peter oh yeah you right okay here
we go
this looks pretty legit I love roller
coaster tycoon take me in that's very
nice
maybe we should get like some
rollercoaster creation tools so it's
like a simulator where you like yeah
it's like a rollercoaster tycoon thing
new owner will be up to the task
rehrberg yes mr. mayor cookies of course
not mr. mayor
sure thing mr. mayor I will succeed
Oh me yeah
did they pave me I'm on there yeah yeah
we gotta build some pavement can I do
yeah that's easy Oh Oh my pavement no
now it's delete some pavement Oh
delete baby yeah to show the to Tori oh
oh okay so you got a place a fair shop
how do we her and shop maybe place on
pavement to open she used to put that
paper down shots okay so yeah there's
fares and their shops
okay so let's face it out the other way
Oh place one fair where can I put it Oh
must face the pavement okay so it has to
be off of the pavement okay I'm
following now got it Oh nope by the way
you're right can I do oh okay um okay
we're getting there we're getting that
we're figuring out cupcake okay oh okay
I see the entrance is that wherever the
arrows pointing got it everything makes
sense here we go okay oh okay so I need
to put pavement here yeah okay big boy
walk put some pavement ok pavement
doesn't cost anything there we go yeah
oh look at that open menu and set are
dt1 Haven kinda looks like floorboards
upgrade oh here oh look a department
yeah okay you want me said 220 that's
what he said yeah that sounds good we
got invest where are the people at okay
so now can I just
oh if I were here I would greet you dude
is that no I thought that was nigel
thornbury I can't sell a damaged fair or
during a disaster where's Brooke from
time okay now what do I do
out here we should add a different thing
open up the menu Oh
oh wait oh is the date is the day
started now it's Tuesday
oh here okay um there's no more chops
but okay get it okay I can't put it here
yeah I think you can't put it on the
pavement okay okay removing put too much
payment we got too excited about
pavement is some good pavement there we
go there we go legit put their salary -
oh if you don't eat aren't you - find
anything okay all right what else
because uh put a bench for people to sit
okay tonight so I only have this much
space to work with a bench like I could
more space yeah you think you can't
expand event shall we rotate you've got
to leave that other one first
yeah no there we go okay all right look
somebody threw some trash in the ground
perfect
oh my goodness Hey just like the Ray
whoa bud Oh some somebody had it can I
pick up garbage no just kind of live
with that oh my goodness
that's not okay
no I'm gonna be there's a being already
on the pier they just didn't use it I
assume that's the bin there's not one a
space
yeah can you build more I don't know
because I'm looking at the menu and it's
like upgrades
I put Barney in the R&D departments ban
pier okay next discoveries in a hundred
years
yeah you see how like the days are
changing the top left corner yeah so
maybe this is like you gotta kind of
wait a little bit look yeah look at that
cupcake legit cupcake
this is big as that man's head you see
I've made a bench you can sit and eat it
someone asks I thought y'all were
playing bleeding-edge for today we
played that earlier yeah oh yeah I
playing hoops nice this is Cory if we
found bleeding edge and dreams very good
make bleeding edge and dreams yeah you
people could like make games they're
excited for like AI not the wait till
March 28th play animal crossing crossing
okay let's check out some other games
all right I'm gonna definitely come back
to this one yeah I've been getting
recommend something called fret star fre
- I hope this is yes there it is yeah oh
is this like a guitar hero thing oh yeah
oh my goodness for sex to rock oh my
let's just go for it
oh man this is sending me back your
shitty son
what do you guys want taking sips from
the the creaky bank we all right see I
love guitar hero back in the day Oh help
me - this is like really for oh okay all
right
oh my goodness I wish I tell you the
whole time I've already forgotten this
is legit pivot controls are the same as
DJ max respect - so let's go
[Music]
copyright strikes on the way okay I'm
ready for it
hope an iron gorillas gonna come after
us
oh how you feelin it
yeah you feelin it I do I'm feeling this
I've just the controls a little over my
head yeah because I wish they'd stayed
on the bottom right I'm like it's just
can't forgot I think it's the left left
left left triangle circle yeah yeah can
you plug in like actual guitar my
goodness that will be amazing
[Music]
doing great feeling it bet no thank you
yeah that's pretty good yeah you want to
try it again here Oh give that a thumbs
up that is amazing all right let's see
[Music]
there were definitely more
recommendations
moving Camus this yeah
insane hell
I think I think I might have saw this
one that's like yeah yeah yeah like a
Japanese horror it's a scary one okay
and it looks legit
about to get a spoon
probably yeah did you buy it did it
plate a little visit legitimately spooky
ain't scare me saying and get some
there's a creepy like tanuki statue that
I got to this menu looks fantastic it's
also everything is goopy and that made
me kind of uncomfortable
oh yeah well you can spray me if you
click on the left stick thank you
first-person certain doors you can you
can open okay got it
that's a closet yeah yeah okay alright
no no it's closed off peek yeah yeah
solve this riddle oh my goodness so good
luck with that I don't think we're meant
for this one did you sell the riddle bin
oh no I went through the door next to it
there's the door next to it yeah it to
the right this is well so you can't go
there cuz you know the flashlight you
gotta go to the flashlight at the other
end of the room down there and to the
left that door there's a flashlight in
there you can grab okay good thing
you're here bad yes thank you
you can turn the light on there those
flashlights on the table to the left
yeah okay a flashlight has batteries
that get eaten up got it
so now you can you can go through that
door and not be afraid because you have
a flashlight not that one the one next
to it yeah this is really good thank you
yeah or maybe not so no there's another
door here that I found that you can go
through oh it's getting good look at all
that gross stuff outside maybe
oh it's further in got it it's in the
back that way
okay this is until there's that sneaky
guy Hey oh wow that is disturbing its
ruling satellite how I also like five
nights at Freddy's I got a battery
that's very important nice light if you
hit the switch over there where that's
that red thing oh there you stand under
it no that's on the wall oh right there
yeah yep oh did I hear twice there you
go
cool hey buddy you got good for a good
first-person look oh yes oh we have a
time limit countdown
do we oh no that's that's the I think
that you're having like health your
mental health
oh you're saying explains why see I was
looking at that I thought that was the
battery meter wait that was the tanuki
causing our sanity to drop yeah I also
feel that way when I see a scary tanuki
with its stomach gone Yap down mm-hmm
you know so this is just where I stopped
okay this is pretty legit under oh
here's a good old sideways Oh jump over
that meat wall
mr. meaty or that oh geez there's so
much stuff here okay that loan share
that's creepy you're staying here let my
Salem you do we want to move on check
some else out yeah thumbs up
a trace of time was about ten minutes
left which is I could've honestly go for
right now I'm down to stay I
unfortunately I've definitely gotten
select a few times about videos being
done that need to be probably Wow I'm
also working on a dreams video yeah
which should go up sometime next week
and I'm still editing that so look
forward to that stars yeah boy Kurt in
Davina post and writer video guy yeah
and also the video guy that real popular
her eyes her absence of ice Oh Kelly
reminds me of Coraline yeah
[Music]
a little Frannie excuse yeah sometimes
you could go a little little too hard I
mean that house is pretty legit looking
that's very good okay
this game a haunted game I might as well
see it scared
I feel like at any moment
it could change
unsettling
yeah that's some blood oh oh yeah that
is look at that
or is it wine
it's going to be that wine but it looks
like blood
wait that's other thing I wouldn't go
down there down there oh oh you know
like look at the lighting yeah more
blood wine inside of the watering can
you know what plants need wine to grow
just something's gonna jump out at some
point probably not looking forward to I
think you could pick something up on
that table I think I was just turning on
a lamp so they're like okay
what's underneath the staircase Harry
Potter chest
Oh cannot do anything my stuck and
seemed very concerned about se-young I
stopped it oh wait I can jump okay well
maybe nothing
what about you
okay lamp
mmm family has so many labs okay
all right I'm not buying that it's wine
anymore that's a knife dude it's just my
wine knife yeah of course you know the
the knife that we used to cut the wine
with that one yup no I'm not buying it
look upstairs those thing that's fraud
where the murder is yeah why would they
murder someone upstairs where it's
harder to get away
yeah it's harder to find it's harder
it's blood on this bed Finn you know
okay well oh-oh I'd hold it nope uh-oh
schematics take a clue maybe maybe Oh
was it like maybe
like that little black square looks like
second floor
hmm oh yeah yeah yeah there's a little
um so go back out to the other side
that door go around here yeah go around
this corner y-yes
okay got it
okay there should be like super thing on
this corner like I think there's a yeah
okay this is the room
it's got books got me something secret
in here I click a book secret entrance
yeah go down there okay it's legit
skeleton skeleton the necklace protects
her oh she lost the necklace
this is gonna be another one of those
sad Jeep ones isn't it oh boo ki KI who
died in here
looks like a reaper oh it's a dead
person okay yep nice
thanks mr. skeleton okay so we're just
really nice drawings yeah how they made
them
I wonder so where's that key do I go
outside what if we died and we came back
to life that's why I had the black eyes
maybe you well you're just gonna be like
what if we died because I believe it
there too I'm like what if we're dead
right now
oh geez what if nothing really exists
okay what if the little girl is actually
playing a dream in her universe that's
us playing a game inside of that okay we
have one more time we're more time for
one more
exit out there's a lot going on there
there's a mystery somebody kept okay do
you want
I'm gonna throw a couple names out there
is ultra realistic FPS concept another
natural disaster dogs run
Bob talks egg bot I want the dog wanted
natural disaster or I want both of those
and Jack the Ripper strikes again oh
there's so many good ones natural
disaster might be interesting because I
want to see like what they got yeah but
also the dog one though blueberry
slaughter well god net what was it
natural another natural disaster would
another natural that's that first one no
just another natural disaster got it
yeah okay list so go this is gonna be
another Godzilla thing the way dreams
intended it spot news is that the way I
know this thing I've seen him before
he's not he's just an axolotl whoa
there's like a tornado over there oh
[Music]
good one I love wait can I say something
into the microphone
no okay damn Oh Jack the Ripper was not
a recommendation but thanks for
including me oh good this was apparently
the Godzilla when someone's asking for
really what we were supposed to find got
it look at how good that city looks well
I'm gonna destroy it bridge over there
it's the San fransokyo it might be but
here we go
oh I like the pickup charge your laser
pick up eat throw emote shoot it shoot
it
yes shoot it
[Music]
video games are good and let me pitch
you on why you should probably buy
dreams for $40 USD in one movie only $40
acts like me you just got it for free
the final version but yeah oh my god
okay what else can I do um look at
bounce
have you eaten anyone yet can I do that
yeah apparently you cannot pick up in
the right trigger to in circle is sing
wait okay so click sing sing like pick
up this house right there are two and in
circle okay yeah our to encircle what's
hurt oh this uh maybe maybe that's the
laser wait instead sing shoot laser are
two circle
what was that singing hush your warrants
Oh hero tail shoot we might have to tell
Godzilla move over okay Tech pick up
this whining spin there we go whoops
okay so r1 plus l3 is tail you need
somebody weird I don't see any people
though do I eat a jet there was a jet
earlier jet flying by I think you can
pick it up here what I pick up things
with trying you think so yeah yeah pick
up okay then eat is square okay
[ __ ]
good destroy all of whatever this
helicopter pick up the helicopter yes
yeah yeah yeah dang I keep eating keep
eating him okay that elevator it's slow
hey this takes place in the future army
universe
oh wait am I getting attacked there's a
natural disaster like a storm happening
at the same time so the screams getting
all dark social collapse seems
inevitable gotta start over
oh there was a dream slow go that was
cute
don't look they're even honoring me on a
sign good thing I don't care about you
it wasn't enough I keep forgetting all
the buttons okay um she's definitely up
again yeah okay
you can't say emote have you done that
yet he's just holding this mouth okay
let me try to emote
oh it's gonna tongue out oh that's cute
anyway lasering that's a really good
laser yeah it sounds good it did the
blooms do get some good camera shake on
there yeah
nuclear strike bang why this thing is
adorable can i fire at the camera I
think so yeah you should probably try to
find a way oh darn it
wait did I survive you fine you only
made me stronger I still I couldn't spot
news
Oh as ice core oh thank you that was an
excellent one oh he's so tired cause he
sleep is he dead ruckus huge thumbs up
for that one absolutely holy crap do you
have time to look at the dog went or
should we actually stop on them I think
that's where we got and what that was
see that was real good that was amazing
yeah wow that was some thank you
everybody submitted your the different
levels from those were thank you some
top tier recommendations and there are
so many that we did not get to though we
should do more dreams we should you
probably do this again yeah absolutely
all right all right cool let's do that
thing Evan do you wanna make dog game
[Laughter]
don't do it Sam
dog Ritter I was gonna say do you want
you want you want to say anything to the
people before we head out I kind of
mentioned earlier but I am working on a
dreams feature if you've seen the video
Kurt and I did previously about like the
death training universe explain and
things like we try to explain des
training similar in scope so look
forward to that and we also made a level
for that video which you will be able to
play mmm when that goes alive
or to that been thank you and John Luke
you probably hear me in the back thank
you for having me on community Fridays
play some dreamy times I've had a lot of
fun it was great it was great this is a
lot of thank you for for chaperoning us
around two core teams but yeah thank you
guys for joining us and hope you have
the wonderful rest to your Valentine's
Day and and weekend hopefully a long
weekend for you too don't forget to
subscribe so you don't miss any of our
shows goodbye goodbye everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
you